so I found Tracy I was like that got
some real bad news to tell you
Alex passed away
[Music]
he was the most outgoing person you'd
ever meet it helps the only problem we
had then I don't think is anybody who
didn't get on with him they'd do
anything for anybody and be surprised
and I'm when he turns up to his funeral
it was about 20 past 6:00 in the morning
one of his friends phoned me up if you
said I'm sorry Tracy I've got bad news
Anthony died this morning
I'm not was it
[Music]
he was a bit drunk before he went out
and he decided obviously I want to go
for a swim
everyone's like now don't do it don't do
it and then he's like if no one comes
with me I'm going to go on my own so of
course everybody went within 5-10
minutes and the spine swimming around I
could see here but you could see me was
talking turned around to come back out
of the water turn around
coming soon
[Music]
he left his flats all happy joking and
never came back out the scene so what
was supposed to be a little bit of fun
turns out not to be quite often people
going to say after they've been drinking
because they think it's fun the effects
of you going in the water can cause
catastrophic problems for you when
you're not in full control of your
actions it's hard every day still 22
months later you don't think something
like that's gonna happen
heartbreaking
you really have to respect the water
because regardless of who you are the
sea doesn't take any prisoners
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]